[Musica]
sono ora che le somaschini ho 28 anni e
sono pilota e distruttore di guida
sicura
vi sarete forse chiesti da dove nasce
questa mia insolita passione se così
vogliamo chiamarla e bene Ora vi
racconto quella che è la mia storia
posso sicuramente dire che la passione
per i motori io l'abbia ereditata da mio
papà anche lui ex pilota da sempre
appassionato e da sempre mio più grande
sostenitore al mio fianco fin dal primo
giorno ed oggi continua a seguirmi in
ogni mia gara anche se avrebbe preferito
che io continuassi a correre in pista e
non tra dirupi sterrati come nel rally
il 3 giugno del 2013 ho realizzato
quello che era un mio più grande sogno
sono riuscita a tirar fuori questo sogno
dal cassetto
e ho debuttato con la mia prima gara in
pista ed ero a casa mia e dell'autodromo
di Monza ed ero proprio in coppia con
mio papà di quel giorno ricordo tutto
ricordo il turbinio di emozioni in cui
ero E da un lato c'era la paura di non
essere all'altezza dall'altro lato
invece
stavo realizzando il mio sogno e quindi
l'adrenalina che ho provato è stata la
cosa che mi ha reso più viva in assoluto
e quel giorno ho capito che non sarei
più scesa da quella macchina da corsa
E così è stato Diciamo che io da quel
giorno non ho più smesso
non solo l'essere una donna è comunque
in un mondo così sapete maschile sono
una delle poche ragazze che corre e
corre in macchina
E questa cosa
Diciamo che non è una cosa che devo
affrontare con le unghie con i denti non
è solo uno sport difficile fisico anche
psicologicamente complicato
Ma oltre a questo oltre ad essere una
donna devo comunque lottare ogni giorno
contro i pregiudizi e i luoghi comuni
che non stiamo qui ad elencare che li
conoscete sufficientemente
e sono veramente tanti quindi
sicuramente uno degli obiettivi è quello
di cercare di cambiare un pochino quella
che è la cultura
della base Diciamo che tra l'altro le
mie scarpe da corsa quindi il mio
sponsor il mio fornitore devono ogni
anno rifarmi le scarpe del mio numero
perché il 35 non esiste a catalogo e
tutte le mie tute tutte hanno tutte la
doppia Zip per poter fare la pipì in
piedi
capite che non mi servirà Oltre al fatto
che quando voglio provare una nuova
macchina devo sempre fare i conti e
lottare contro una posizione di guida
che non è studiata per persone della mia
statura e della mia stanza e quindi
quasi non mi godo questa nuova vettura
perché devo passare tantissimo tempo a
poter regolare e trovare una posizione
che sia non solo comoda e utile per
arrivare a tutti i comandi ma
soprattutto sicura
nonostante questo l'essere donna non è
l'unica e principale cosa che mi
distingue dagli altri miei colleghi
tutti i miei colleghi o quasi tutti
hanno magari seguito quella che era una
passione di famiglia e
partendo magari dai go kart quindi dalle
basi Mentre io da piccolina Dovevo già
fare i conti con qualcosa di molto più
grande di me
e
far dar conto a tantissime
responsabilità più grandi di me
il 18 febbraio del 1994 è cominciata
quella che è la mia battaglia più dura
che devo combattere ogni giorno
la battaglia contro la fibrosi cistica
se ci penso Ho passato quasi la metà
della mia vita a curarmi
e dopo 30 giorni dalla mia nascita i
miei genitori hanno ricevuto una
telefonata dalla clinica dove sono nata
dove lo scrivino Natale aveva dato dei
risultati alterati i risultati sono
stati poi confermati da un test e sudore
alterato anomalo con dei valori sballati
e quindi la diagnosi ormai era certa
fibrosi cistica
Chi di voi conosce Che cos'è la fibrosi
cistica
motivo per cui sono qua è cercare di
farla conoscere il più possibile la
fibrosi cistica è una malattia genetica
grave che colpisce i principali organi
interni e sono proprio polmoni fegato
pancreas ed è la il danno polmonare che
determina la quantità e la quantità
della vita
in Italia ci sono 8000 malati
e una persona su 30 è portatore sano del
Gene mutato e quindi se incontrano un
altro portatore può generare un figlio
malato pensate in questa sala quanti
siete e quanti sono i potenziali
portatori ma non lo sapete perché non
avete alcun sintomo
la diagnosi è stata un fulmine a ciel
sereno per i miei genitori
E comunque viverla ogni giorno è
veramente difficile Non solo per la
malattia in sé ma perché proprio io la
voglio definire subito la subdola perché
non è solo la routine Il problema è
proprio l'incertezza verso il futuro tu
fai dei programmi Ma non sai se
effettivamente questi andranno in porto
Perché c'è sempre lei che potrebbe
rovinare tutto da un momento all'altro
l'esempio che faccio per capire la
fibrosi cistica è quello di respirare da
una cannuccia la fatica che fate a
respirare da una cannuccia è proprio la
fatica che i malati di fibrosi cistica
quando raggiungono comunque uno stadio
piuttosto grave devono
affrontare per respirare e respirando la
cannuccia a fare qualsiasi attività
giornaliera
l'aspettativa di vita oggi è di circa 40
anni ma quando sono nata io nel 1994 era
esattamente la metà 20
capite bene che è un è un dato che fa
male leggere
nella sfortuna di essere nata con questa
malattia mi reputo abbastanza fortunata
perché nel mio caso la fibrosi cistica
si è manifestata in una maniera un
pochino meno aggressiva perché ogni
malato ha due mutazioni una ridata dal
papà e una della mamma e una delle mie
due mutazioni è di quarta classe Quindi
un pochino più lieve però questo
l'abbiamo saputo Dieci anni dopo la mia
nascita perché la ricerca ha fatto dei
passi avanti ha studiato le mutazioni E
alla fine ci hanno dato questa notizia
però capite che i primi dieci anni sono
stati veramente voi
per me e per i miei genitori
ogni giorno devo affrontare questa
routine di cui vi parlavo e la routine è
fatta di cure
Io la mattina mi sveglio faccio
colazione prendo le mie 10 12 pastiglie
poi torno devo fare le terapie e le
terapie sono diciamo un esercizio
respiratorio che ti permette di allenare
i tuoi polmoni una sorta di palestra per
i polmoni e ti permettono di mantenere i
polmoni e le vie aeree pulite
io pensate che da piccola pensavo che
tutti i bambini del mondo dovessero fare
la terapia perché per me era talmente
una parte fondamentale della mia
giornata mattina e sera che pensavo che
tutti dovessero farlo e pensate che per
un periodo vedevo mio cugino che
probabilmente avrà avuto un banalissimo
raffreddore fare l'aerosol e quindi io
avevo la prova che tutti i bambini del
mondo facessero queste terapie
in realtà non è così
Questo l'ho capito un giorno quando era
alle medie e si studia genetica come
sapete e la mia professoressa parlava di
diverse malattie genetiche tra cui la
fibrosi cistica quando la professoressa
parlava recitava una lezione che io
sapevo già perfettamente ne avevo già
sentito parlare vedevo di volantini in
casa avevo letto più volte su una porta
del mio ospedale la parola fibrosi
cistica e quindi ho detto la conosco
però non avevo associato che potesse
essere un mio problema
Ecco quello Forse è il momento in cui ho
capito tutto
e la professoressa ha detto i bambini
con questa malattia non raggiungono
l'età adulta quindi io come se avessi
visto un fantasma sono sbiancata e
quando sono arrivata a casa da mia mamma
l'ho guardata quasi con le lacrime agli
occhi gli ho detto
Dimmi la verità dimmi che non è vero
perché mi stava crollando il mondo
addosso
lei si è seduta
ha respirato e mi ha detto guarda che
lei non ti posso dire qual è la realtà
perché non la sappiamo non c'è un malato
di fibrosi cistica uguale all'altro
quello che posso dirti è che noi fino ad
oggi abbiamo fatto tutto il possibile
per renderti la vita più semplice
dandoti una mano non facendoti sembrare
questa routine un peso ma parte della
tua vita della tua giornata
e questo mi ha un pochino alleggerito e
poi mi ha detto Posso dirti che noi ce
la metteremo tutta per fare del nostro
meglio
a quel punto ho detto ho avuto un
periodo veramente difficile forse il più
difficile mi sono chiesta Ma perché a me
cioè perché è proprio io devo fare
questa cosa e devo affrontare questa
cosa e forse ho capito i tanti no che mi
erano stati detto fino a quel momento
poi ho capito Mi sono rimboccata le
maniche come spesso faccio e nel mio
carattere e ho cercato di ristabilire un
equilibrio cercando di vivere come avevo
vissuto fino a quel momento
semplicemente facendo come dice Come
direbbe mio padre Prima il dovere e poi
il piacere
e diciamo che la valvola di sfogo tutto
è stata la mia passione
io fin da piccola ho sempre avuto questa
passione per qualsiasi cosa avesse
velocità e man mano mi stavo avvicinando
sempre di più prima con le moto Poi con
le macchine e la forza l'ho trovata
proprio portando avanti la mia passione
quando io allaccio il casco allaccio le
cinture non esiste più niente e lì sento
veramente di essere nel posto in cui
vorrei
Oltre al fatto che ho capito che
nascondersi non serviva nulla e che
avrei potuto fare qualche cosa per
quelle persone che invece la forza di
realizzare i propri sogni non ce
l'avevano e quindi ho deciso di parlarne
di portare alla luce questa malattia per
cercare anche di essere di aiuto per gli
altri
quello che dico sempre è che non esiste
una Rachele solo pilota una Rachele solo
affetta da fibrosi cistica Io sono
entrambe e per questo ho voluto fondare
un progetto che si chiama correre per un
respiro
è nato con me dalle primissime gare e
cresce con me in ogni successo sia
sportivo sia personale
nel 2015 ho vinto all'anno del debutto
quello che era un trofeo in pista il
mini challenge e contemporaneamente
parlandone facendo eventi raccogliendo
fondi tramite i volontari e alcuni
banchetti di sensibilizzazione raccolta
fondi abbiamo superato i 25 mila euro di
donazioni raccolte nel 2016 l'anno
successivo ho cambiato specialità e ho
iniziato parallelamente anche a correre
nel campionato italiano velocità
montagna vincendo quella che era la mia
la classe sempre con la Mini e le
donazioni raccolte sono duplicate più
che duplicate 60 mila euro di donazioni
raccolte
nel 2018 ho debuttato per la prima volta
nei rally e anche lì la raccolta fondi
andava avanti fino ad arrivare ad oggi
nel 2022 che abbiamo superato solo nel
Motorsport solo con correre per un
respiro i 300 mila euro di donazioni
raccolte
c'è una cosa che porto sempre con me ed
è una frase
me la Ripeto ogni giorno e me l'ha
lasciata in eredità quella che era una
delle mie più care amiche Angelica e
questa frase ce la dicevamo nei momenti
più difficili
Diciamo che Angelica aveva una forma di
malattia di fibrosi cistica molto più
severa della mia fin da subito e quindi
ha dovuto anche le responsabilizzarsi
fin da quando era piccola e combattere
contro questo mostro grande però era
sempre lei a darmi la forza non so se
solo per il fatto che lei magari c'era
già passata
ma lei era proprio fatta così
e quella che sono oggi sicuramente una
parte la devo lei per la forza che mi ha
saputo trasmettere e per il suo modo di
essere il suo amore che strizzava da
tutti i pori che mi ha trasmesso l'amore
per la vita
oggi Angelica avrebbe compiuto 30 anni
ma purtroppo la fibrosi cistica se l'è
portata via a soli 25
quindi capite bene che è una battaglia
che va combattuta con le unghie con i
denti
in quella frase trovo la motivazione per
andare avanti e per andare sempre più in
alto
oggi la ricerca ci ha lasciato un
farmaco veramente fondamentale ma è
disponibile solo per il 70% dei malati
di fibrosi cistica e questo farmaco mi
dà i cavalli in più per andare sempre
più lontano e per raggiungere obiettivi
sempre più grandi
sei tutti i limiti che superi L'ho
tatuata sul braccio e l'ho voluta
mettere sulla macchina in una posizione
ben visibile quando entro in macchina In
modo tale che quando entro e quando mi
metto la guida e allaccio le cinture io
posso avere la forza e la determinazione
per superare ogni difficoltà cercando di
puntare sempre più in alto nella gara
che sto correndo come anche tutti i
giorni della mia vita
[Applauso]